c'est le style gorille j'espère que vous
allez bien vous commencez à le savoir on
passe en revue le programme des
candidats à la présidentielle et
aujourd'hui on se plonge dans le
programme de eelv yannick jadot en dix
mesures j'ai l'impression de radoter à
chaque fois mais évidemment je peux vous
présenter toutes les mesures de son
programme en détail là on va à
l'essentiel
je vous mets évidemment le lien de son
programme complet en descriptions et
comme pour tous les candidats cette
vidéo est accompagnée de l'interview de
yannick jadot que je vous mets en
descriptions ali disponibles sur cette
même chaîne youtube du coup nous
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne pas
louper les interviews suivantes aussi
alors on va commencer par une petite
présentation kia nick shadow et bien il
a 54 ans il s'est d'abord engagé dans le
milieu associatif
il a notamment travaillé dans plusieurs
ong dont le ng2 défense de
l'environnement greenpeace
il est membre du parti les verts depuis
1999 qui est devenu par la suite europe
ecologie les verts en 2010 et il est
député européen depuis 2009 il a
remporté fin septembre la primaire de
son parti en battant au second tour
sandrine rousseau puisqu'on parle
justement de la présidentielle il avait
déjà été candidat à la présidentielle en
2017 mais il n'était pas allé jusqu'au
bout il s'était donc rallié au candidat
du parti socialiste benoît hamon voilà
ça c'est donc pour sa présentation et on
va donc voir ensemble désormais ses dix
principales mesures s'il est élu
premières mesures on va parler
directement d'écologie car c'est le
thème central porté par yannick jadot et
son parti il souhaite sortir de
l'élevage industriel donc cette méthode
d'élevage qui consiste à exploiter un
maximum d'animaux dans des surfaces
réduites et au passage c'est la première
mesure qu'il appliquera s'il est élu
président alors pour sortir de cet
élevage industriel il veut commencer par
interdire l'élevage en cage et les
élevages d'animaux à fourrure c'est une
mesure qui est plutôt populaire puisque
82% des français sont favorables à la
fin de l'élevage industriel selon un
récent sondage de l'ifop pour le jdd la
deuxième mesure phare de yannick jadot
sur l'écologie c'est de sortir du
nucléaire d'ici 15 à 20 ans en fermant
dix réacteurs nucléaires d'ici à 2035
pour arriver à cette sortie du nucléaire
d'ici 15 à 20 ans il veut notamment me
et sur les énergies renouvelables et
notamment sur les éoliennes je veux
arriver à 12000 éolienne d'ici la fin de
son mandat contre 9500 éoliennes qui
sont présentes aujourd'hui et au passage
sortir du nucléaire c'est une mesure qui
est porté par de nombreux candidats à
gauche sauf l'occurrence le candidat du
parti communiste français fabien ou
celle qui lui à linverse souhaite rester
aujourd'hui dans le nucléaire la
troisième mesure environnementale forte
de nick shadow c'est la mise en place
dès les 100 premiers jours de son mandat
d'un isf climatique donc un impôt sur la
fortune payés par les plus riches qui a
été supprimé en l'occurrence par emile
et le maquereau anne hidalgo propose
elle aussi la mise en place d'un isf
climatique sauf que anne hidalgo veut
reprendre en fait il y est c'est fait
que la france avait déjà mis en place
avant mais dont l'argent récolté serait
dédiée à la transition écologique dans
le cas des ninjas dos et un petit peu
différent le en fait tu veux faire un
impôt sur la fortune qui serait modulée
en fonction de l'impact environnemental
des plus riches en gros il veut taxer
les plus riches est pénalisé en plus
ceux qui participent au changement
climatique que ça pourrait donner par
exemple c'est un impôt sur la fortune
plus élevés pour les français qui font
des placements financiers dans des
entreprises qui sont émettrices de façon
importante de gaz à effet de serre
quatrième mesure et yannick jadot voter
a indiqué la grande pauvreté et pour ça
il veut mettre en place un revenu
citoyen versée automatiquement alors
cette somme d'argent versée elle serait
pas de 920 euros pour tous les habitants
enfonce en fait ce serait variable selon
les personnes mais l'objectif justement
c'est de s'assurer que personne en
france ne se retrouve avec moins de 920
euros par mois l'idée est donc de
garantir à chacun ce montant et dans le
but également d'améliorer les conditions
de vie des personnes les plus modestes
yannick jadot souhaite augmenter le
salaire minimum donc le smic 225 euros
dès fin 2022 pour atteindre donc environ
1400 euros net par mois contre 1200 sont
9 euros actuellement une augmentation
qui est similaire à celle souhaitée par
jean luc mélenchon sachant que yannick
jadot souhaite ensuite que ce salaire
minimum passe à 1500 euros net par mois
d'ici à 2020 c'est cinquième mesure
unique jadot propose d'augmenter les
salaires des enseignants d'une moyenne
d'environ 20% actuellement selon les
derniers chiffres disponibles sur le
site du ministère l'éducation nationale
le salaire moyen d'un enseignant en
france et de 2490 euros nets mensuels
mais vous l'imaginez la rémunération
varie énormément en fonction du statut
de chaque professeur et des
établissements il veut également recruté
65 mille enseignants supplémentaires
pour baisser le nombre d'élèves dans les
classes un nombre qui juge actuellement
trop élevée selon lui à noter au passage
que ya une autre catégorie de
travailleurs dont yannick jadot veut
tout augmente et spécifiquement le
salaire ce sont les personnels soignants
il veut en fait une hausse de 10% des
salaires du personnel soignant il compte
également embaucher 100 mille infirmiers
s'il est élu 6e mesure désormais yannick
jadot veut faire en sorte que les
français travaillent moins et pour ça
ils envisagent la semaine de quatre
jours ou encore les 32 heures de travail
par semaine contre les 35 heures qui
sont en place aujourd'hui c'est la règle
principale et de base alors selon lui ce
à améliorer les conditions de travail et
ça permettrait de retrouver un équilibre
entre vie privée et vie professionnelle
qu'il juge en fait nécessaire cependant
il ne souhaite pas imposer le passage
aux 32 heures à l'ensemble du pays en
fait il est plutôt favorable dans un
premier temps à ce qu'il appelle une
convention citoyenne donc des débats et
des discussions sur le sujet ou
réfléchir donc à ces sujets là s'il est
élu président ces mesures yannick jadot
veux je cite déverrouiller les
institutions et pour ça il souhaite
notamment supprimer le cumul des mandats
pour un prise dans donc supprimer le
fait qu'un président puisse être élu
deux fois d'affilée il souhaite au delà
allonger le mandat présidentiel à 7 ans
au lieu de cinq ans actuellement il veut
également mettre l'assemblée nationale
au coeur de la démocratie est en gros il
veut notamment recentrer les pouvoirs
sur le parlement qu' on est donc plus de
pouvoir alors que aujourd'hui bien le
pouvoir est très centré autour du
président de la république la huitième
mesures proposées par yannick jadot
c'est son plan pour lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes il prévoit
d'investir un milliard d'euros dans la
lutte contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles pour je cite prévenu détecter
et sanctionner les violences sexuelles
et sexistes et protéger les femmes
exposées par ailleurs il veut à inscrire
le droit à l'ivg et j'ai donc
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans la constitution qui est donc est la
loi suprême du pays le droit à l'image
et deviendrait ainsi un principe
fondamental de notre république
française et enfin toujours dans cet
objectif d'améliorer les droits des
femmes yannick jadot a déclaré vouloir
une assemblée entièrement paritaire avec
une femme à la présidence de l'assemblée
nationale et une première ministre la 9e
mesure de yannick jadot concerne
l'international il considère la chine
comme je cite une dictature d'une
violence absolue il souhaite donc que la
france soit plus ferme face au
gouvernement chinois il dénonce
d'ailleurs régulièrement l'accord
d'investissement qui a été signé entre
l'union européenne et la chine en 2021
alors que les voix s'élèvent ces
dernières années pour dénoncer notamment
la situation des ouigours cette minorité
musulmane persécutée en chine alors au
cours de mon échange avec lui dans
l'interview à face cachée démontré aussi
favorable à un boycott des marques dont
les produits proviennent de la région où
sont persécutés les we go enfin dernière
mesure pour terminer ça concerne la
sécurité le candidat des écologistes
souhaitent remplacer l'igpn donc la
police des polices elie ggn qui est donc
la police de la gendarmerie pour les
fusionner en un seul organisme qui
serait en l'occurrence indépendant du
ministère de l'intérieur est rattachée
au défenseur des droits en gros beaucoup
aux reproches à sept gpm donc cette
police des polices d'être trop
complaisante vis-à-vis des policiers
notamment dans les cas de violences
policières et pour lui pour résoudre ce
problème et bien ça passe par davantage
d'indépendance de cette police des
polices alors vous en doutez on n'a pas
pu a détaillé toutes les mesures comme
pour les autres candidats autrement ce
serait impossible dans le cas des ninjas
d'eau par exemple qui à près de 120
mesure mais voici quelques mesures
supplémentaires et nick shadow souhaite
abaisser le droit de vote à 16 ans comme
pas mal d'ailleurs deux candidats à
gauche il souhaite aussi à supprimer
parcours super est créée par la même
occasion soixante à cent mille places en
première année dans l'enseignement
supérieur yannick jadot vote aussi
légaliser le cannabis ou encore
reconnaître le burn out et la dépression
comme des maladies professionnelles
yannick jadot veut aussi créer 700 mille
nouveaux logements sociaux
et enfin en ce qui concerne l'âge de
départ à la retraite il ne veut pas
modifier l'âge de départ à la retraite
contrairement à son nom de candidat lui
souhaite donc le maintenir à 62 ans
voilà donc pour cette présentation du
programme de l'élite jadot évidemment
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à cette
chaîne pour nous soutenir et pour ne pas
louper les vidéos suivantes de
décryptage ou d'interviews des autres
candidats je le dis aussi sur instagram
on a posté pas mal de contenu exclusif
concernant à la présidentielle dans les
prochains jours du coup nous n'hésitez
pas à nous suivre le nom du compte c'est
hugo décrypte écoutez je crois que j'ai
tout dit fraser ne vous présentez vos
proches et on se dit du coup a très vite